[Musik]
hallo hatte vollkommen zufällig fällt
heute in meinem video geht es um das
thema sell on tour denn wie bereits in
den letzten jahren werden wir auch
dieses jahr wieder umziehen und von ss
danke und die messe saison starten
lassen
dieses jahr gehen die messen in milow
und ich erzähle ich ein bisschen was aus
den letzten jahren also wir haben
angefangen vor zwei jahren auch messe zu
gehen
jeder bau sogar um ein grad verbreitet
traf 43
so ist das eine jahr geblieben
vor drei jahren auch helfen wir auch
messe gegangen und damals war alles noch
in diesem provisorisch wir haben tische
mit tischdecken überzogen und kirche in
kalifornien hat alle sind ich hab
familienmitglieder mitgenommen und
freunde mitgenommen haben uns geholfen
aufgebaut bei vielen auch schon gab es
damals nicht aber es war trotzdem
immerhin alles schön pink eingedeckt und
formschöne und familie
mit der zeit wurde das ganze natürlich
immer größer und ich hab gemerkt oh
jetzt kommen immer mehr menschen das
heißt wir müssen professioneller werden
und haben dann auch unseren messestand
immer ein bisschen weiter ausgebaut
jesus maria und mittlerweile letztes
jahr war es in dortmund zum beispiel
gehabt also wenn ich mal zu sagen kann
wie messehalle schuppel gesprengt
hannover hamburg wasser ziel und habe
das auge nicht doch da war es die
messehalle
ob ich auf der messe explodierte haben
abgesperrt und dann bin ich raus
gelaufen und habe meine zuschauer und
draußen in der schlange bescheid gesagt
dass er auch noch rein dürfen ja
jedenfalls war dortmund hannover
wasserlos als es war immer eigentlich
viel los egal wo wir waren
und wir haben natürlich ganz ganz viel
spaß gehabt und ich freue mich dieses
jahr schon richtig auf die urlaubssaison
muss ich schon sagen auch die mittel
saison und wir werden in diesem jahr mit
der messe in österreich starten
da war ich jetzt schon seit meiner
schwangerschaft nicht mehr
das heißt in der schwangerschaft da war
die l a noch fünf wochen in meinem bauch
seiner wahl
österreich habe die befürchtung dass und
da war ich das erste und letzte mal
leider dort und in diesem jahr ist
rihanna auch schon gesenkt käufer das
heißt sie darf dann bei der oma pleiten
und und ich darf wieder mit meinem team
auf messe gehen ja in diesem jahr sind
wir auf der kuren messe in welt und das
ist eine richtig tolle und vor allem
sehr große messe und da bin ich dann mit
meinem stand das heißt wir haben über
900 quadratmeter und das gigantische
rappen also wirklich wollt eure texte
sitzen leute
wir haben den zauber oder bei uns stimmt
wird nämlich dieses mal also warum auch
aus den letzten jahren gelernt das war
immer ganz schön aber es gibt natürlich
immer diesen konflikt entweder stehe ich
in der küche und ihr dürft mir beim
kochen und backen zu schauen
mit mir sprechen wer unterhalt und und
stellt mir fragen oder ich hab natürlich
die andere szene und das ist dann die
bei der autogrammstunde
das heißt dass ich dann da stehe und
autogramme geben eure bücher signieren
eure schönsten sieg mehrere
autogrammkarten machen oder mit euch
zusammen fotos machen und ich würde am
liebsten immer alles gleichzeitig machen
das heißt sowohl letztlich stehen
einfach autogramme und fotos machen aber
ich kann mich noch nicht verteilen und
deswegen hatten wir immer wird das
problem die die schon im autogramm
hatten wollten mich natürlich in der
küche sehen und wie die noch kein
autogramm hatten wollten natürlich nicht
mehr zu gucken und lieber ein autogramm
zwar dem zwiespalt und dieses jahr haben
wir das gut gelöst dass wir auch ein
kleines rahmenprogramm hatten
das heißt wenn ich dann bei der
autogrammstunde bin und in der küche
praktisch nix los ist wenn jetzt morath
keine suppenküche ich hoffe ja da kommt
von bisher nach futter kraffel
aber wir haben noch einen vw rat werner
der die noch gesellschaftlich oder
jahren der victoria sind nun zwar ist es
ein freund des zauberer und feuerspucker
und der hat auch ein cooles programm
vorbereiten auf das mich schon riesig
darauf wieder eingehalten werden
ein aber wir verteilen zum beispiel
getränke und essen zu teilen wir ja was
los alle zuschauer haben ein paket haben
immer das war ja die leute unterhalten
die familie sei ich sind die
eintrittspreise auch der moderator
zwischen vier und zwölf euro jeder
wir müssen auch das zu sagen wir gucken
immer wenn wir auch messe eingeladen
werden als wenn wir werden oft gefragt
möchte der messe besuchen und dann
gucken wir immer macht den
eintrittspreisen das heißt wenn die
eintrittspreise zu hoch sind dann gehen
wir da gar nicht erst hin oder wir gehen
hin aber wir sagen euch dann ich
beschreibe es heißt dann sind wir
einfach nur da um das zu feiern
aber ich möchte nicht dass sie auf eine
messe geht um mich zu suchen kommt und
wirklich mega hohe eintrittspreise
bezahlen ist und eintritt dörfer
eintritt wir haben am ende zieht es noch
ein paar karten zu verlosen
genau wir haben 100 karten für felgen
und 100 partner dortmund
denn dortmund wer die nächste messe sein
und da war letztes jahr da hat mir schon
eine richtig große halle also da hat mir
schon eine halle für uns alleine und das
war mega als ich weiß noch wie heute als
die rolltore aufgängen umsehen und meine
zuschauer alle wie eine frau bei
versammeln vorne dran gewartet haben und
dann irgendwie auf das los sein ich mir
eingebrannt ist war schon ein mega mega
tolle andere ständen genau das gibt auch
ganz viele andere stände aber ich freue
mich jetzt schon auf alle messen
und ja die anderen stände handel
natürlich auch im kuchen und torten
backen koch zubehör und bei uns nicht
einfach zufällig backen und kochen und
wie gesagt gegen den fragen stellen und
dem rahmenprogramm gibt das shop ist
natürlich auch mit dabei und auch den
haben wir dieses jahr etwas vergrößert
was wir haben ihn ziemlich sekunde weil
da immer stau war und man kann sich
nicht bewegen
aber man muss dazu sagen wir sind keine
professionellen messebauer wir sind
einfach nur verlieren hat die mit den
jahren davor gelernt haben genau also
ich war aber auch wiese 27 lkw sowieso
mit 740 vorher dachte ich da mit meinem
und schraubendreher und bau mit dem
messer auf für uns dann gehen wir immer
noch einkaufen in einem supermarkt in
der nähe und es ist dann auch immer ganz
witzig mit 345 einkaufswagen daraus
vorgenommen würden von morgens bis
abends da an allen tagen alarm nicht nur
dass georgien und sagen wir machen eine
chemie autogrammstunde lach ich will
gerne am morgen
wir kochen backen aber immer spaß
zusammen und wieder alles probieren wird
bestimmt mega cool
also ich freu mich natürlich immer auf
die messen weil ich dann auch mal meine
zuschauer kennen lernen kann
ob sich auch oft also manchmal will ich
auch bekannte gesichter wieder das heißt
viele besucher mich auch ein zweites und
drittes und da freue ich mich auch denn
gerade bei kindern zum beispiel wie sie
wachsen und ja ich sehe einfach meine
zuschauer immer wieder sie teilen mit
was sie gerne am nachkochen nachbacken
was gelingt und das ist schön so der
austausch und ist dennoch freue mich auf
neue schulden ja wir haben doch ko und
und bin martin turner in hamburg war
menschen freundschaften und wird richtig
lustig ich glaube auch wir haben
versucht gerade über zu finden der vng
kuriert er weiß genau als fleisch falls
sich jemand von euch da melden möchte
wir brauchen einfach jemanden besser und
sie sind offen der kurier online gehören
ihr genau der den zuschauern in fürth
zeigt wie man mit von bearbeitet damit
die euch einfach fragen stellen können
das heißt falls ihr interesse habt auf
der messe in wels und haben dort niemand
bei uns haben da man ja also wie gesagt
wir freuen uns sehr auf die messen lasse
noch sagen wollen falls ihr kleine
kinder auch mitnehmen
dann werden wir schauen dass die
bevorzugt werden dass sie dürfen dann
immer mit nach vorne
denn von zehn die kleinen kinder hinten
gar nicht und auch wenn er eine
behinderung haben zum beispiel im
rollstuhl sitzt werdet ihr immer mit
nach vorne geholt das heißt achten wir
darauf auch bei schwangeren zum beispiel
dass ihr einfach nur um die christine
getreten genau wie gut nicht
zu essen dass es genug gibt mit seinem
audi weg zu teilen das als große ehre
wir müssen so ganz ganz sicher auch
meistens genau ein schönes familien
event wird weil ich weiß dass man
seitens der familie kommt ein preis ohne
dabei egal für eifrige unser kunst aus
dem westen haufen geld er heißt du
kommst ja alles uns genau und wechselt
mit nummer kurz die termine am erwähnen
das heißt anfang mai sind wir auf der
messe in wels in österreich ende mai
sind wir in dortmund auf der messe und
zwischendrin gibt es noch einen mini
kleines event und zwar ist es in
epfenbach huber uns in sinsheim das ist
es events bei meiner freundin jasmin und
zwar hatte da einen makel und beauty
studio und letztes jahr wollten wir das
schon machen arbeiten wurde sie leider
krank und er musste das ausfallen lässt
dieses jahr werden wir das einen tag vor
muttertag durchführen und da freue ich
mich auch schon drauf und hoffe
natürlich dass wir tolles wetter haben
denn zwischen open r
wenn wir für ganz kuschelig an bord ganz
kuschelig und weitere 65
weiters heißt also wir haben nur eine
straße und von dort auf das ganz
schnuckelig dort nun wirklich schön und
da freue ich mich auch auf alle die aus
der umgebung sind und damit dabei sein
möchten die karten die wette verloren
haben wir haben 100 freikarten für
dortmund und 104 welt das heißt wir
verlosen 2 x 550 x 2 karten
warum bringst dich mal zwei karten für
welt und für dortmund und dafür schreibt
ihr einfach eine e mail an die unten
eingeblendete adresse wir haben zwei
verschiedene e-mail-accounts damit
einfach nichts durcheinander kommt das
heißt wenn er auf die messe in wels
gehen möchte schreibt ihr an dieser e
mail adresse schreibt peter euren namen
und die vollständige adresse in die
e-mail mit rein und am besten noch in
den betreff messe wels und fallt ihr
nach dortmund möchte schreibt ihr an
dieser e mail adresse und schreibt da
auch euren namen eurer adresse und messe
dortmund ohnedies dienstag bescheid
dann seid ihr also dann habt ihr die
freikarten augen
aber wie gesagt ansonsten sind die
eintrittskarten auch nicht teuer antwort
diesen weg nicht aus
also die dann gewonnen haben bekommen
eine antwort und falls ihr mit dienstag
die antwort hat dann hat ihm die karten
geworden und dann bekommt ihr einfach
per e mail bescheid genug glauben wir
alles erzählt uns erwähnt oder ja und
dann gehts dann haben wir somit kleine
sommerpause und dann geht's einfach im
spätjahr wieder weiter aber bleibt es
dann im sommer wahrscheinlich immer
wieder und wird bei youtube
ihr könnt natürlich alles sehr liebevoll
facebook abonnieren auch bei instagram
denn dort verkünden wir auch immer oft
die termine usw
weil wir können nicht jedes mal wenn zum
beispiel der terminänderung oder
irgendwas wäre ein video machen also
jetzt haben wir zwar das beste video die
messe termine stehen auch fest aber auf
facebook und instagram bin ich halt ein
bisschen flexibler das heißt da kann ich
auch immer mal ganz kurzen posting
machen und euch immer über alles
informieren
wie die letzten jahre bitte keine
geschenke mitbringen denn wir haben
alles was wir brauchen und es hat euch
keine umstände machen und außerdem haben
wir auf der messe das ist aber ganz
wenig platt ich habe eine ganze
gefriertruhe voll mit suzuka bitte auch
in den letzten zwei jahren verstorbene
frau nicht zeigen
das kann schon anderes mal zeigen aber
wir haben wirklich sehr braucht nicht
mehr angehalten ganz extrem weiten wege
auf euch genau denn so ein messer tag
ist auch anstrengend und wir möchten
nicht dass wir dann noch ebene extrem
weit hergereist seit ich glaube murat
jetzt haben wir alles gesagt wir freuen
uns alle schon auf die messe
da hat mein handy geschnappt danke
zurückbringen danke
zum glück gibt's die kinder sperre und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
biss dann ja und was ist in österreich
ein wenig reinlassen haben 890 irgendwas
ich glaube die vorlesungsreihe stand
vielleicht nicht mehr raus
maximilian haas hallo
[Musik]